-Our next guest
is a very funny comedian
whose stand-up special
"Good Clean Filth"
is streaming now on HBO Max.
Let's take a look.
-I found the best way
to discourage something in bed
that you're not into
is to try to get them
to not be into it on their own,
you know?
Try to ruin it for them.
So, I gave in at first.
It was hard, but I was like,
"Oh, yeah, does daddy like that?
What about this?
Does daddy like this?"
And by the end of it,
I was just like,
"Dada! Dada! Dada!
Dada! Dada! Dada! Pbht!"
-Please welcome back to the show
Nikki Glaser, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Hi, Nikki! How are you?
-I'm so good, Seth Meyers.
-You look wonderful, as always.
-Thank you. I forgot a bra.
-Oh, well.
-Aw. Sometimes happens.
-Sometimes that's how it goes.
-You know what I realized?
-What's that?
-I look like you.
-Ohh.
-I have makeup on, but that's
really the only difference
between our faces.
-Yeah.
-We have the same face,
and it's --
I am flattered
that I look like you.
I'm complimenting myself,
and I'm not insulting you.
-Well, I've always found you
very attractive,
so this makes sense now.
-That's so -- [ Laughs ]
Like a true narcissist.
Exactly. Like, yes.
No, I realize, though,
that most women's faces
without makeup just do look --
You can pretty much
pair them with a guy
because guys are just --
We have the same faces.
For instance, if I was to ask
the audience to, like,
draw a picture of a smiley face
and I go, "Now make it a woman,"
what would you do?
You wouldn't, like,
scribble a vagina.
Like, no one even knows
how to draw one of those.
You wouldn't, like,
make it holding less money.
You would just add eyelashes.
It's what sets...
women and men apart is makeup,
so thank God for it.
But do you know
who we look like?
And this I was hurt by.
-This is late breaking news.
You brought a photo.
-I just came up with it
backstage because I go,
"Oh, my God,"
because someone told me
I look like this duo.
But now I go, "I got a partner,
and now we look like this duo."
We look like the Nelson brothers
from Nelson.
[ Laughter ]
Get up here with me.
-Yeah, there we go.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
-I mean, look at us.
Look at that.
-There you go.
-It's -- It's spooky.
And I like it.
So thanks for sharing it
with me.
-I mean, I've always been
a fan of theirs, too.
This is all coming together.
-Do you ever -- Have you ever
put on makeup?
Have you ever like --
Sometimes I see a guy's face
and I'm like, "I just want to
get a little eyeliner in there."
-I remember I played
one of the cast members
in a "Desperate Housewives"
sketch in "SNL" back in the day.
-Yes.
-I looked great, yeah.
-You would!
It's amazing what it does.
It's, um --
I spray tan my body constantly.
Like, my regular pallor
is probably like
a Uncle Fester-ish color,
and when people recognize me
without makeup,
I honestly get offended.
I go,
"You think I look like this?"
'Cause I spray paint my body.
I use Sally Hansen leg spray.
This is all painted on.
It's all gonna --
My shower is gonna look like
the water in Flint, Michigan,
when I bathe later.
That is not an insult.
It's a problem. Let's fix it.
[ Laughter ]
-It is. Let's fix it.
-Yeah, that's still happening.
It's a nice reminder of it
in that joke
that I made fun of them.
-We were talking backstage.
You moved back
to your hometown...
-Of St. Louis.
-...of St. Louis at the
beginning of the pandemic,
and then it took.
-I was scared because
the world was shutting down
and I didn't have
comedy clubs and podcasts
to fill my life with,
and so I was like,
"I need to go
to Mommy and Daddy."
And so I went back to St. Louis
for what I thought
would be like two weeks,
like we all did,
like, "Until this blows over."
And then I lived there
for 10 months
with my parents in their house
at the age of 35.
I eventually had to move out
because it was getting
embarrassing to have people
ask me where I was living
and I'd say,
"I live with my parents,"
and they'd be like, "Why?"
And so I got rid of that
therapist, and I was like,
"I don't really want
to talk about that anymore.
Can we talk about
why I'm so talented?
Like, I loved
when we focused on that."
But I eventually moved out,
and then I got an apartment
and I lived there
and I had a reality show
based on me living there.
-And St. Louis appreciates it.
They had Nikki Glaser Day,
April 28th.
-Yes. I think it was
just a one-time thing.
-You don't think
it's gonna be every April 28th?
-Oh, I would love it so much,
but it was --
it was Nikki Glaser Day.
I, as a comedian,
absolutely love attention.
But this just felt like --
I came up with it,
so it felt so embarrassing.
It really was --
E!, the network
that my reality show,
"Welcome Home Nikki Glaser?" --
still streaming on Peacock...
It was --
E! bought Nikki Glaser Day.
You can buy a day in the city.
And they gave me a proclamation
from the mayor.
They gave me a key to the city.
-Wow. Double key.
-Double key.
-Double-key guest day.
-I know! You're getting 'em all.
-And you threw out a first pitch
at a Cardinals game.
-Yes, at the Busch Stadium.
Threw out the first pitch.
Which I did not want to do
because I'm not athletic at all.
I got first voted off
"Dancing with the Stars."
It's like --
It's traumatic for me.
-Yeah.
-But I accepted
because it's every --
It's, like, my boyfriend --
It's all my best guy friends'
Make-A-Wish to do this.
So they're like,
"You got to do it!"
So I did it, and I did not do
as well as I wanted.
I will not watch the footage.
I don't know how it went.
People keep sending it to me
as an abusive tactic.
I block them.
-Is that bad
that we have the footage?
-Do I -- Can I close my eyes
a little bit?
Can I watch it
like I watch "Saw"?
-I think -- Why don't --
Hey, wait.
Why don't you
close your eyes completely
and then, just by
the audience reaction,
try to picture what it is?
-Okay.
-You tell me if this
was as bad as 50 Cent...
-Okay. Here we go.
-...and his first pitch.
-Here's Nikki's first pitch.
-Oh, God.
-Here comes the windup
and the pitch.
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, Nikki!
-Do you see me? Ugh!
Oh. I was so sad.
I cried so much later on.
-No, you didn't.
-I -- Oh. Oh.
-That was great!
-It was so bad.
It was so embarrassing.
But the worst part
of that whole thing,
the catcher
that I was throwing --
that I tried
to throw the ball to
was the guy who lived
in my apartment building.
I flirted with him.
I hit on him one day
by offering him a dog treat
in the lobby of our hotel --
or of my apartment building,
which I thought would be funny
because I was offering --
I go, "Hey, you want
to a treat?" to my dog.
And then I go,
"Do you want a treat?"
And then I thought
that was a good line.
We had a conversation
in the elevator.
I then DM'd him to be like,
"Hey. Nice meeting you."
Never heard back. So then
I had to pitch the ball to --
This was my second pitch
to that guy.
And it -- That one was worse,
actually.
-He probably saw that pitch,
and he was like,
"The one that got away."
-[ Laughter ]
-Literally.
-Yeah, exactly.
-He was like...
-So, wait. You have a wonderful
new stand-up special on Netflix.
You have always been --
-No. HBO.
-Oh, excuse me. I'm so sorry.
Let me reboot it.
-I got one on Netflix, too,
but HBO.
-Great.
Just dabble, everybody.
-Try them all. But HBO.
"Good Clean Filth."
-And the other one is --
And your reality show's
on Peacock.
-And my reality show's
on Peacock,
and "FBoy Island" is on HBO Max.
-So you got a lot
of networks covered.
-I got it all covered.
-But your new HBO
stand-up special,
you have always been really open
about talking about sex,
especially in a way
that we never get to talk
about in this society,
but I want to ask.
Your parents --
Obviously you're close.
You went and stayed with them
during a pandemic.
How do they feel about
watching a show like yours,
which is very open about things
that are usually
behind closed doors?
-They are such supportive
parents, and I didn't realize
that they hated it so much
until they were on my reality
show and I heard --
You know those like --
where they do
the individual interviews
during reality shows
and you watch them and you go,
"Why would this person
be saying this stuff?
Don't they know people are
gonna hear what they say?"
Like, my mom did that to me.
She was in an interview
and she was like,
"You know what?
If she wasn't my daughter,
I wouldn't go to her shows.
I wouldn't be a fan."
And I go, "Mom,
it's supposed to go --
Did you misspeak?
If I wasn't your daughter,
maybe you could stomach
the stuff that I..."
She goes, "No, I would
hate it if -- I only go..."
I look at everyone and I go,
"I can't believe
all these people love you.
I can't --
I can't believe it."
That's her way
of complimenting me.
But I'll take it.
-That's kinda...
There's a sweetness
somewhere in there.
-She loves that people love me.
It's sweet.
-And what about your dad?
-My dad is the sweetest,
so supportive.
He went to my Netflix special
taping, which was a couple ago,
and I kicked him out
during the middle of it
because it occurred to me
that it might be
uncomfortable for him.
And it was the first time
that it occurred to me.
And he goes,
"It was the first time?"
And I said, "Yes, Dad,"
because I have to shut that off.
If you're at a show --
I would hate if I went to a show
and I saw Cardi B
and she was like,
"Listen, you guys,
my dad's in the crowd tonight.
I can't do 'WAP.'"
I would be like, "This is...
This is the wrong show
I came to."
So I don't hold back
if my dad's there.
But he did not come
to this HBO special taping
because he told me
that oftentimes when he comes
to my shows afterwards,
people come up to him
and treat him like
he's at my funeral.
They're like,
"Are you okay, man?
Like, do you want us to bring
a casserole by later this week?"
Like, he really suffers a lot,
but they are so supportive
and I'm really lucky.
-Second season of "FBoy Island."
Give a quick pitch
for those who haven't seen.
-Okay, the quick pitch is I have
not met one person who says --
Everyone always says, "I don't
usually like reality shows,
but I love this one."
You don't have to
like reality shows.
You can be one of these people
who thinks you're better
than them, but you're not.
This show is amazing.
It's addictive.
It's called a tour de force
by "Vanity Fair."
And it's funny. I'm hosting it.
All the things
you do on your couch
to make fun of these shows,
I'm doing it as the host,
so just give it a try,
and I bet you'll be hooked.
Three episodes up now
on HBO Max.
-That is a pitch, everybody!
Nikki Glaser!
"Good Clean Filth"
is streaming now on HBO Max.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."